and so I guess let's talk about that
right sigh I think a lot of people
forget especially people are coming into
crypto now you've got Brian and Fred as
to the co-founders Olaf's obviously one
of the first employees or I think he
might even been the first employee
these guys have all gone on to kind of
run different things that are leaders in
their specific niches of the crypto
space and so like what were those early
days like as you're talking to them and
talking to others in space like help us
understand what's going on in the early
days of coinbase yeah I guess what
struck me is how hard these guys worked
I mean I guess that's just the world of
startups but I mean they were really
like working 18 hours a day it was Brian
you know I mean there's a bit of
intrigue at the start because he was a Y
Combinator company and you know Sam
Altman
you know the founder of Y Combinator
told me that their model is they want
co-founders because building startups
too much work on their own but when at
the outset I mean wired reported this
years ago it's a guy named Ben Reeves
for the you know old crypto guy started
blockchain he and Brian entered Y
Combinator as co-founders but right on
the cusp of starting someone at Y
Combinator whispered in Brian's ear hey
you got to cut this guy loose because
there was a ideological division because
Ben Reeves was like we can't you know
have a semi centralized service you know
it's got em and you know but Brian was
like look the whole points making it
easy and we're you know so basically he
booted his co-founder with the
complicity of Y Combinator at the outset
built it up but the reality is you know
he needed someone else and a few months
later Fredersen was goldman sachs trader
who got disillusioned by how
technologically stupid goldman was moved
to the west coast and just met Brian and
read it and then the two of them just
like you know busted their ass building
it all of course and we of course now
runs poly chain he was a frigging
lumberjack I mean he's sort of a
character he was working in the state of
Washington like as a lumberjack and he
was willing to Bitcoin and he turned up
in San Francisco and said hey guys kind
of work for you and you know that that's
how they started real synergy there they
added a another engineer named Craig
Hamill and then
Charlie Lee who of course is famous for
litecoin and that was the original team
and you know there's something about
when you have people who mesh like that
and work hard together and that's I
think how they they launched it yeah I
guess it's really interesting when you
think through not only that small team
but but there's some irony in Brian
Armstrong and Fred coming together
giving Fred's background from Wall
Street which is that there's definitely
a ideological divide like you described
where not only do you get inside of
Krypton but like Krypto is an
ideological divide from the traditional
Wall Street right and so to see somebody
crossover like that so early and go
build infrastructure there did Fred kind
of give any insight into I'm assuming
his former co-workers thought he was
crazy and kind of the classical story or
were they more encouraging and really
want to see him go for this no he was he
was disillusioned because he was you
know in in Goldman and he was a trader
but he had a real you know he's got a
real talent for software and obviously
he realized we're you know this was I
think when would this be like yeah 2012
2013 where there would have been less
the floor traders and the culture of you
know those firms is like liars poker
it's you know kind of like big athletic
dudes who you know showed each other
down in a pit whereas you know all the
while you know they the guys who to
build algos were you know coming in but
you know Fred was describing how the
Goldman people disdained you know the
computerized traders who treated them as
the IT staff and you know he just saw
where the future was going you know in
his words but obviously he's turned out
to be right and so that led him to to
leave and it's funny so apparently his
you know his co-workers were like you
know haha what's that or I don't know if
he knew he's gonna do crypto but when he
got into coinbase he went to his one his
former manager the one guy who did get
tech and was like hey do you want to buy
an early shot could coinbase for $25,000
and you know I wish that guys sitting
very pretty right now yeah and so
there's this famous photo of a Brian
Armstrong and I forget where it is but
it's in the early days of coinbase he's
got a coin based shirt on if I remember
correctly it's basically at like a job
fair or some sort of event and he's
literally like handing out t-shirts and
and I remember asking somebody about it
and I don't want to say who it is but
they basically like yeah people forget
that at one point
Quinn days didn't take off at first and
there was talk of potentially even like
should they shut it down where cuz
actually wasn't working and then it kind
of really took off and so kind of how
when you were writing the book like how
did you think about the various phases
of the company and kind of that you know
hard work overlaid with this just a
psychological toll it takes on founder
working on something that not only is
just hard to build a company but it's
also in this industry that kind of sort
of existed but but not a lot of people
really recognized it you know in 2014
and things like that yeah and that's a
great point pong because I mean that's
startup life you know most of them fail
but they were in a hole in just you know
you do you know if the whole industry
was gonna make it so that's even more
existential yeah I mean you know it's
you know that the peaks and valleys of
crypto 2013 it went on you know a bit of
a run and ya know what the prices got up
to but then it you know collapsed
entirely again like I think it's like
that's where it's revenged a thousand
bucks you know in the early early days
it went from 30 bucks to two but in the
next uptick I think was 2013 hit almost
a thousand and then the floor fell out
and yeah talking there I mean they you
know they had their venture funding by
then so they could write it out but I do
know in the first crypto winner in 2014
people confided in me that they drew up
a plan to you know to can forty percent
of their staff because they always
wanted to keep it to year runway and
then you know just as happens ever so
often then the prices started ticking up
again and they were able to hold on so
it's you know it's a series of events
like that
and I think it's true to this day you
know you'll have these you know massive
frenzies of trading and all the
exchanges you know make a bunch of money
and then things go really quiet and you
know things shut down things get
acquired people get laid off but you
know here we are again yeah and another
player that uh that came from coinbase
and now is gonna do other really
impressive things is Adam White and I
know that there's some stories about
Adam in in the books maybe kind of share
one or two of the really interesting
things that that Adam went through while
working at coinbase
yeah I mean Adam White's one of the good
in crypto you know he's just a you know
really stand-up dude I think he has no
enemies worked really hard interesting
story too I mean he was a you know a
fighter you know he's in the a fighter
pilot in the UM in the Air Force and you
know so he served his country and then
went to come back to Harvard Business
School took him to you know and he's so
humble he admitted it took him two tries
to get in he got rejected he you know
wrote and rewrote his application got in
and around them and he got into Bitcoin
and it's sort of funny that he you know
he tried to write about this at Harvard
Business School on they're like no no no
this is friend just as flaky so and you
know this is complete self-promotion I
think it's awesome the my books coming
up in print it's out an audio right now
but it'll be out in print in December
and the publisher is Harvard Business
Review so this sort of shows how how far
things come but but you know Adam yeah
he's so he was basically the sales guy
he you know he buses asked to go and get
people to sign up to take you know
merchants you know and his challenge was
Fredersen told him you know sign up like
you know ten billion dollar companies
and he did which is amazing but
unfortunately you know as we learned you
know that never was bitcoins game you
know because remember there was his time
where everyone thought oh and people
gonna pay with Bitcoin merchants want
Bitcoin and so it's not all these people
up but you know then always see not much
came of that well my favorite story with
Adam is some later in the game and strip
around I think twenty sixteen around
there when things were taken off Brian
Armstrong coinbase sent him as an
emissary to New York you know cuz he's
kind of a like button down so you know
he looks the part he looks like a banker
and it's like go get some of these like
old school you know firms on board so he
gets a meeting with Cantor Fitzgerald
which you know is sort of as like
classic Wall Street as you can get you
know we're talking like scotch and
three-peat suits and steak houses and
you know so he goes to meet he gets the
meeting and he shows up on his own and
the CEO of Cantor Fitzgerald comes with
like ten guys and Adam has no tie on and
his title was like general manager and
they started mocking him saying like
what's a general manager you gonna get
my coffee and he basically got left out
of the room
and I think that's less reflection of
Adam than it is just the prejudice of
Wall Street not only against crypto but
against westco's culture you know and
that's something I think you know the
crypt of communities reconciling with
right now
you know Silicon Valley and Wall Street
at very different places are coming
together but you know just look how
people dress in the valley look at the
dress in Wall Street and you know
culture is a big part of companies to be
part of industries and that's what we're
seeing right now